so today we're talking about commercial
architecture which means
no fancy tricks no transitions no
background changes
just straight to the point and very
commercial focused
what's going on guys my name is david
thomich and welcome back to the channel
today we're talking about my top five
tips for commercial architecture
and what you need to understand before
you go into a meeting with your first
commercial client
so commercial architecture is all about
business and understanding the business
itself
your new commercial client is going to
want a good understanding of
their business and you as a business
operator
so as an architect in commercial
practice it's all about you
understanding their business and their
business model
the better you understand this the more
you know about this
section of their life the more they're
going to want to use you as the sole
architect on their next commercial
project
so tip number two like i said no messing
around here today
is make sure you add value to their
business if you can understand their
business model you can definitely add
value to their business
for example if it's a restaurant it's
all about seating numbers and it's all
about
operational efficiency if you can get
people in and out of that restaurant
quicker or if you can get more tables in
a limited amount of space
you're doing these people a favor and in
the long term you're making them more
money
so you're definitely adding value to
their business and you're being a better
commercial architect
number three what you'll understand in
residential and in commercial
is budget blows out very quickly in
commercial
more so than residential because
commercial items cost
a fortune so if you're doing commercial
architecture make sure you brush up
on your knowledge on every single item
that might be going into this commercial
property
for example if you're doing a warehouse
they might be needing forklifts
racks sprinklers all sorts of different
things for
restaurants for example they might also
need some sort of commercial fridges
range hoods all sorts of different works
so it's your job to understand
these critical points in their operation
number four commercial is all about
timing
commercial projects are on a tight time
frame
more time equals more money for your
clients so make sure you get it done
in a timely manner and make sure you
establish this
very very early on no client wants you
to waste their time
and effectively waste their money in a
commercial project
especially if they've got a deadline to
open say it's
december january whatever 2022 2024
whenever it is you need to make that
deadline and you need to make sure
everybody in your project team is aware
of those deadlines
so remember time is very much so money
when it comes to commercial projects and
last but not least commercial
architecture is
very different to residential
architecture residential architecture is
more or less a simple process meet the
client
get it through council get attended get
it built it's
relatively simple when it comes
commercial there is so much more
involved so make sure
you understand the process and the
legalities behind it
the last thing you want to do is get
caught up towards the end of a project
because you didn't know
a step one of these steps could be the
make or break between an additional 30
days in this project that you completely
didn't even know about
so make sure you understand the
legislation in your country and
make sure that you understand the
processes of commercial architecture
anyway that's all for me today guys
extremely quick video
because it's more or less in line with
the commercial theme
time is money so make sure you listen to
these five tips and if you enjoyed the
video make sure you smash that like
button down below
if you want to see more of my content
smash that subscribe button because as
always
i'll see you next monday